-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
Now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden criticized
Georgia Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor Greene yesterday,
and suggested that her politics
are causing Republicans
to join the Democratic Party.
Oh, come on,
we can't even get Democrats
to join the Democratic Party.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new poll,
68% of voters said that
President Biden is too old
for another term.
I don't know. I mean, okay,
he's an 80-year-old man.
But the job is mostly
telling long stories
that don't go anywhere...
[ Laughter ]
...signing whatever
a young person hands you...
and arguing with foreigners
and drug companies.
Man for the job, I say.
The House Foreign Affairs
committee voted yesterday
to advance a bill
that would allow
President Biden to ban TikTok.
Ban it? He hasn't even
figured out how to download it.
[ Laughter ]
"Hello,
TikTok customer service?"
[ Light laughter ]
A spokesperson for
the Chinese Foreign Ministry
said today that the U.S.
should cease weapon sales
and military contact
with Taiwan.
Oh, what are you going to do,
send another balloon?
I'd like to see you try!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, damn, that was fast, wow.
It's right outside.
Vermont Senator Bernie Sanders
recently released a new book
titled "It's OK to be Angry
About Capitalism."
And if you still don't believe
him, you can look at the price.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Bernie Sanders recently
released a new book titled
"It's OK to be Angry About
Capitalism."
And if you like that, check out
the rest of the books in his
"It's OK to be Angry"
collection.
[ Laughter ]
The Supreme Court
heard arguments yesterday
in a dispute between
New York and New Jersey.
It was the case of "ayy!"
versus "oooh!"
[ Laughter ]
A very subtle...
very subtle but real difference.
[ Light laughter ]
"The New York Times"
published a profile yesterday
of a man who has
lived his life mostly barefoot
for the past 20 years.
And bad news,
he's on your flight.
[ Laughter ]
Producers have announced
that actress Bebe Neuwirth
will return for the revival
of the sitcom "Frasier"
to repr-- to reprise --
excuse me --
her role as Lilith Sternin.
Not returning, Eddie the dog.
[ Audience aws ]
Yeah, you guys thought you
didn't like that barefoot joke.
[ Laughter ]
You didn't realize that --
those were the heights.
[ Light laughter ]
Officials at a zoo in Nebraska
this week
confirmed that a cheetah briefly
escaped from its enclosure.
Oh, good, only briefly.
It's just a cheetah.
How far could it have gotten?
[ Laughter ]
It was chasing Eddie.
[ Light laughter ]
According to a new survey,
the Tooth Fairy now leaves
more than $6 per tooth
on average,
which explains
the recent increase
in seven-year-olds
taking up hockey.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a cruise line
is now accepting reservations
for the first ever
three-year-long cruise,
two years with good behavior.
And...
that was the monologue,
everybody!
We're off and running.